damn look
she choked her out she tapped what wow
[Music]
the hardest finest baby dude we got a
champ do not cry that's amazing No Cry
Cry you're not about to cry you're not
about a good cry no you beat Chucky
that's because you think you also think
entertainment
I think that's why legit yeah somebody
who cries I feel like they're not even
thinking about entertainment dude all
they're all they're thinking about is
Mexico has two children four walls they
lived in the entire training camp Oh
that's [__] Chef tanko that's insane
and now it was coming because Chef
changer did not look right in her last
fight a lot of people thought she lost
that fight so this one
you ever cried Rampage